from NPR news this is all things
considered i'm robert siegel and i'm
michele norris a lot of struggling math
students have found comfort in the sound
of this man's voice welcome to the
presentation on using the quadratic
equation salman khan started making math
videos to help tutor his cousin but they
became so popular he quit his job with a
hedge fund to work on them full-time now
his online Khan Academy attracts
countless teachers and students NPR's
Larry Abramson reports on the first
effort to bring Khan's approach into the
classroom it is shocking three dissolute
students in Northern California are
using school time to play a computer
game what's it called trigonometry
challenge ok one-half what 2x oh yeah
fifth graders Michael on Lucas Ewan and
Reese to marry are actually hip deep in
the trigonometry challenge at Khan
Academy they're gobbling up math
problems like a plate of Doritos the
school is part of a pilot program at
santa rita elementary school in Los
Altos California they're making the Khan
Academy an integral part of the math
curriculum teacher kami thordarson says
for half an hour a day Crown Academy
dunks these students into a completely
self paced world they're all in
different places some of them are
working on calculus in high school math
some of them are working on
multiplication of decimals and that's ok
it's ok because students who need help
can look up the appropriate video and
listen to the academy's explanation of
concepts like direct and inverse
variation so I'll do direct variation on
the left over here and I'll do inverse
variation or two variables that vary
inversely on the right hand side over
here so Salman Khan scribbles on the
video screen and guides students along
with his signature approach patient and
unthreatening kami Thordarson says kids
are comfortable turning to con for help
it's kind of a private thing it's not
like you have to raise your hand in
front of the whole class since I don't
get this you can go not get it on your
own and nobody needs to know about it
there's nothing flashy about the videos
or the exercises but somehow Khan
clearly hit a sweet spot that makes this
the most popular part of the day so that
you square that a 36 and you square that
that's nine kami thorgeirsson says
during con time her class looks more
like a busy engineering office than a
traditional classroom kids collaborate
the teacher facilitates and she doesn't
have to lecture some kids like Hannah
Albright work on their own following
online exercises as they do calculations
and a whiteboard or with pencil and
paper 9-7 it's like an online teacher
they can help you anywhere because
patches you watch yeah you don't have to
wait are we going to do any development
next door in Kelly Rafferty's class kids
put their name on the board some want
help on a concept others offer to teach
something that they've mastered Rafferty
says that Khan helps her deal with the
big class sizes that even this affluent
district is facing Khan has definitely
helped me reach all of the students so
when you have that many kids you end up
sort of teaching to the middle and Khan
has allowed me to reach the lowest and
the highest much more than a textbook
work rafferty says Khan Academy also
offers a kind of back office function
while kids are working independently on
exercises Rafferty checks your computer
to see how they're doing so with this I
can look at all the kids and I can see
who's struggling who's not which they
passed how many it took for them to pass
so it gives me a lot more information
information she can use to see who needs
extra help Santa Rita elementary
principals Sandra McGonagle says for her
the Khan Academy has some big advantages
over other math batir 'i'll 'he's one
it's free and it's created by people who
really just love math and the quality is
so great after this year's pilot program
the Los Altos schools are going to start
using Khan Academy district-wide for
fifth and sixth grade the Khan Academy
is hoping to see how this experiment
plays out in a wider range of schools
they expand to at least 10 new schools
next year math class may never be the
same
okay okay yeah yeah Larry Abramson and
PR news